si je vous propose maintenant d'aller au
théâtre pas très loin
on vous me direz vous qui regardez ça
n'évoque peut rien pour vous si je vous
dis que nicole cornu d'emplois notre
journaliste a traversé la rue c'est vrai
à d'une montagne à paribas sachets comme
ça que nous sommes tout près de la
comédie des champs-elysées et nous
retrouvons là bas sophie desmarais pour
fleur de cactus de barillet et grédy
bonjour madame vous m'entendez bien
dites moi c'est un retour au théâtre
parce que vous ne pouviez plus ça vous
démange et ou alors parce que vous êtes
tombé sur une pièce que vous connaissiez
qui était du solide
d'abord la pièce est formidable et
hallyday de la rejouer rôle dans les
avignon est un rôle merveilleux
et puis comme disent les gens branchés
je devais avoir un monde quelque part
dans mon vécu de plus comédienne que je
ne le pensais
et puis jouer avec jacques ronnie mise
en scène par lui avoir une troupe
formidable ça me plaît avec nelly pas
toujours très gentil avec vous dans la
pièce jacquat non il nous fait des tas
de méchanceté mais ça c'est un rôle et
dans la ville est très très grand pied
avec moi alors là on est dans ce taux
longs je dirais plutôt que c'est les
malheurs de ronnie font les bonheurs de
sophie haricots dans la pièce je sais
mais banner qui provoque son bonheur
final vous êtes dentiste on est
d'ailleurs en votre cabinet la ville est
menteur en plus comme un arracheur de
dents
et donc je suis avec une petite amie qui
s'appelle antonien cette petite antonia
je ne veux pas du tout cas elle nous
accapare alors je prétends avoir une
femme et des enfants voilà mon gros
mensonge
j'ai dit que j'avais une femme et trois
enfants et les aussi alors voilà je suis
obligée de demander à ma secrétaire
n'est ce pas ces deux charmantes
mademoiselle vigneault alias sophie
desmarais de jouer le rôle alors elle
vient dans le magasin viens voir ma
petite amie pour lui prouver que j'ai
devant alors on va tout de suite dans le
magasin c'est un marchand de disques
eva rivet ce magasin jeudi morts
mademoiselle k voulez-vous de plus mais
c'est qu'il ya aussi les gens sont les
enfants vos enfants je n'oublie pas que
julien est le père de vos enfants
oui oui et oui il ya aussi les enfants
et bien je vais pouvoir enfin me
consacrer à eux peut-être jusqu'à
présent les infos négligé pour me dévoue
à leur faire il est très exigeant vous
savez notre travail de travail
elle était aussi un peu sa
collaboratrice ah bon je croyais qu'il
avait une assistance en janvier fille
amoureuse de lui j'avais qu'ils avaient
ça non mais d'après sa description c'est
comme ça que je me l'imaginais va vous
vous trompez pas nous alignons n'a pas
vos radios 20 ans mais elle est pas mal
du tout mais je vous assure vous vous
n'avez jamais été jalouse elle jalouse
demoiselle ligne ou alors je dois avouer
que ça ne m'est jamais venu à l'esprit
d'ailleurs s'il m'avait fallu me montrer
jalouse de toutes les eaux avant ce ne
devrait pas vous le dire mais j'en ai vu
défiler à bombay
il était résident paye la tête car je
suis persuadé qu'avec vous tout ça va
changer conseils sont semble n'être pas
là enfin pas encore mais pour en revenir
à mademoiselle dinho elle n'a jamais est
amoureux de leur part je tiens à le
préciser
tant mieux aujourd'hui julien tient
beaucoup à elle assez minime la défense
non mais il m'a souvent répété que ça
doit être difficile à trouver une bonne
et s'y sentent pas cher je devrais
peut-être en faire une alliée qu'en
pensez vous je deux cas très bon départ
vous êtes vignon reste au service du
docteur elle ne supportera pas la
présence d'une autre femme que moi dans
la maison je vois pas pourquoi
et bien moi je vois et ben tant pis on
se rappelle d'ailleurs que vous
n'importe mazel vignes en savoie
mademoiselle winning oui nous sommes
dans un autre décor nous sautent dans un
cabaret et là la situation va s'arranger
entre vous oui nous mais elle va évoluer
très vite parce que nous arrivons au
terme de cette émission encore un petit
million ce qui t'est regrets voilà mais
nous avons tous les acteurs autour de
nous voilà il ya ce n est plein et on
espère bientôt la salle va être pleine
passant à la pièce le mérite c'est une
merveilleuse comédie de barillet
et grédy une comédie qui déchaîne des
rires youtube c'est là partiront
d'ailleurs à la face à la crise tordu
avant elle a été adaptée au cinéma
également alors c'est à partir de quelle
date 8 mars à partir du 7 conviés à
venir nous voir
samedi prochain le 7 mars merci et
sophie des marais merci jacques ronnie
merci à tous et à bientôt